the Civil Society she is the MP for
Wigan worked for the charity sector
before she was an MP and is now of
course
um the Shadow the shadow Secretary of
State for leveling up housing and
communities so we'll listen to a short
speech by her and then maybe take some
questions Lisa now thank you so much
well thank you very much
that was the introduction just read out
a list of all the jobs I've been sacked
or demoted from over the last 13 years
let's hope this time I managed to level
myself up and get into government in
order to change what is a completely
unsustainable situation across the north
of England no more excuses we can't go
on like this after 13 years of virtually
no growth across this country we can't
fund our Public Services Chief amongst
them as many of you in local government
in this room will know is social care
and the crisis in the National Health
Service our Crown Jewel Public Service
run down to the point where millions of
people can't get treatment and patients
lie on the floor in a e departments
across the country
our high streets are to communities what
the a e is to Health and Social care
it's the warning light that flashes on
the dashboard that tells you that the
system the wider system is fundamentally
broken
behind every boarded up High Street is a
local economy that is failing failing to
grow failing to put money in people's
pockets failing to give young people
choices and chances so they don't have
to get out in order to get on and that
is our failure as politicians not theirs
after a decade of Decay and decline so
much is broken in Britain but Chief
amongst them our political system
today the north comes together to
discuss our Collective future
but we're doing so much more than that
in this room right here today because
this country's inability to Grapple with
every major challenge that we now face
struggling Public Services the cost of
living crisis failing Town centers an
aging population an energy Revolution
that will lead no family untouched all
of that comes back to one thing that
we've written off the talent the
potential and the assets of most people
in most parts of Britain and this has
been going on for too long this isn't
just a tragedy it's a social crime
Britain is almost unique in trying to
power a modern economy using only a
handful of people in a handful of
sectors in a few small parts of the
country and my friend Carson Schneider
who addressed this conference earlier
told me in Germany last year that while
they're taking two countries and are on
a journey to turn them into one what
he's seen in Britain is taking one
country and taking it on a journey to
turn it into two now that has left us
with a crisis but it's not just a crisis
in the north it's left us as with it
with a crisis in London and in our major
cities of housing of air pollution and
extraordinary levels of poverty and
strain on public services and it's left
us with a one-word plan for the rest of
Britain redistribution
to find our way out of this National
malays we needed to be bold instead we
got a lecture on the merits of the Roman
Empire we got Hunger Games style system
where ministers choose who gets a
Leisure Center some picnic areas and
traffic light improvements from behind a
desk in Whitehall I was born in the
north I was raised in the north I was
educated in the north I'm bringing my
family up in the north and I have no
truck with some of the headlines that we
saw this morning it's Grim up north
really
but what's Grim is business and
political leaders who are forced to go
cap in hand to Whitehall to ask
permission for what we know works and
our communities that are completely cut
out of that conversation
so together we're calling time today on
this short term arrogant sticking
plaster approach that leaves us lurching
from crisis to crisis we can't go on
like this
in Bradford in Sunderland in
aberdeenshire through arts and culture
through wind and hydrogen the ambitious
proud people and the political leaders
that back then you can Glimpse what the
future could look like the councils who
are pioneering Community wealth building
the Mayors taking back control of our
buses and yes Steve our trains
the the medicine were going off some
pioneering new ways of having influence
there's a reason why the fabulous Tracy
Braden could go over to India and bring
back a thousand jobs to West Yorkshire
she knows her community she fights for
her community and she understands not
just the problems that Whitehall
obsesses with but the potential that
exists across the whole of West
Yorkshire and not just in Leeds
the communities that are reclaiming our
housing stocks Street by Street The
Business Leaders who are investing in
our natural assets even when the
government won't ambition is everywhere
in the towns Villages and cities that
were once the engines of Britain but for
too long have been written off and
written out of our national story
and for 15 years it's a global financial
crash the failure the catastrophe of
running an economy like this has been
plain to see but every time the public
has sounded the alarm
hitting our politicians with tsunami
after tsunami of discontent are creaking
political system has done nothing
we can debate the merits of different
Evolution models and funding formulas
but this this is the collective task
facing our generation of political
leaders to respond to that siren Call or
face obsolescence to change or die we
must succeed where successive
Generations have failed in various ways
to varying degrees for a century and we
must do so for one simple reason because
ending A Century of centralization and
unleashing the power of all people in
all parts of Britain is no longer a nice
to have or a local or Regional issue it
is at the heart of whether this country
has a future or not it is the only way
to heal a fractured and divided nation
it is the only way to build an economy
that works for most of us again so we
can fund our public services and sustain
thriving places in short it is the only
way to build a country that works
now why would you trust us
to do our parts when you've had
commitments to change from every
aspiring government in recent decades
it's spawned too many versions of
Enterprise zones to count
and an endless round of Northern
Powerhouse press releases with every
single promise broken
why would you trust an agenda that lives
or dies at the whim of whoever happens
to be prime minister that term or in
recent times that week well I'll tell
you why
because we're going to bake this in to
our program for government across the
whole of government not just one
minister or one Department
a covenant between you and us and the
British people and today I want to tell
you how
firstly we believe that to have strong
thriving resilient communities
particularly in our Coastal and
Industrial towns that have so much to
offer this country doesn't need one
National growth plan but hundreds of
local and regional growth plans driven
by you and the people that you serve
based on the brilliantly diverse assets
and skills and geography across our
country for too long all we've talked
about in relation to the north of
England is redistribution from here on
in we will replace that word with
contribution to empower our communities
to take control of their own economic
future and to take charge of their own
destiny
So today we're firing the starting gun
on the biggest transfer of power out of
Whitehall and Westminster in British
history with one simple ask tell us what
you need to create strong local
economies and thriving inclusive
communities and we will back you there
are a million good jobs on the road to
Net Zero and a global race to get them
why shouldn't young people in Barnsley
and Bolton have the chance to Paris
through the next Century like their
parents and grandparents powered us
through the last that's why we've
committed to the biggest investment in
green energy transition in our history
to underwrite the economic growth plans
created by the people who live in those
communities and see assets and potential
where Whitehall sees only problems to
bring back good well-paid jobs to places
that were once the engine room of
Britain and if you write the plan we'll
support the jobs of the future and hand
you the tools to deliver in all places
not just some secondly in our first King
speech we'll bring forward plans to flip
the presumption of power from Whitehall
to the town hall through the Take Back
Control Act
oppositions tend to like the idea of
handing overpower government's a little
bit less so so if you ask for Powers we
will place ourselves under a legal
obligation to hand them over or explain
why not and if there are reasons why not
we will be obliged to set out a path for
communities to realize that ambition for
every part of Britain and the people in
them
no more top-down determinism of which
communities qualify for powers and which
don't no more central government
dictating local governance models as a
bargaining chip in the ACT will be a
promise written into law that leaders
can request anything that has already
been devolved to another area of similar
scale within England so that every part
of Britain that wants to will take
charge of its own destiny on housing
transport energy Child Care skills
employment support and training with the
right to run their own bus services and
invest in the rail tram and bus networks
they need and to drive major
infrastructure problems not from Western
projects not from Westminster but from
South Yorkshire from merseyside from
teesside working together across the
north because if Northern Powerhouse
rail have been put into the hands of the
north without constant interference from
government you can bet that our Northern
leaders would have delivered it by now
and deliver it in full
we know that the power to deliver
Services means nothing without the
ability to plan for the long term with
the funding and resources to deliver
them now I want to level with you here
Rachel Reeves has been clear that the
next Labor government will have
iron-clad fiscal rules because it's
people's money and as many of you know
in this room they don't have a lot of it
so every penny that we spend is the next
Labor government will be spent wisely
but that means it will be spent by the
right people in pursuit of the right
aims which is why national government
spending will line up behind those local
growth funds not ad hoc pots of funding
short-term pots of funding without the
ability to plan but national government
rolling in so that when leaders are
Great Northern leaders like many of them
in this room today whether it's Jamie or
Andy or Steve or Ollie or Tracy and our
Council leaders as well well brilliant
Beth Craig showing exactly what can be
done from right here in Manchester when
those leaders write their local growth
plans we will line up government funds
behind them because is there anything
more absurd unstrategic or anti-growth
than having to bid into two different
departments for buses and for bus
charging points now I'm I'm hopeful that
there is a political consensus that
longer term funding settlements with far
more Flex in the budgets of the future
the current system is deeply frustrating
for all of you in government it will be
frustrating for us and it is totally
undemocratic leaving you accountable to
Westminster not the people you serve for
how money is spent so time is up we're
going to do things differently we'll
usher in a new generation of Civic
leadership by empowering and supporting
local government offices everywhere to
rebuild their capacity for consistent
first-rate management of public money
the planners and The Architects that you
need to build beautiful places expertise
in procurement trade and finance we know
how badly this has been hollowed out and
will provide the support to rebuild this
capacity across local and Regional
government drawing on those places first
and foremost where it still exists and
from whom so much can be learned
and with this capacity in place we'll
provide the route for local authorities
and Mayors to take on properly
integrated long-term funding settlements
with greater Financial
certainty and the ability to plan for
the future no more smoke and mirrors
announcements from central government
genuine power and decision making and
resources for communities to deliver for
themselves
now this is a brilliantly diverse
country it's a bright brilliantly
diverse region and we're comfortable
with different communities doing things
differently
some of us are not more equal than
others and never again will we allow our
political system to behave as though we
are which is why the Take Back Control
Act will also put into place the
recommendation by the future of the UK
commission that there should be a
constitutional requirement to rebalance
the UK's economy and equalize living
standards across the country over time
but the route to achieving this doesn't
lie through raising more taxes on
working people who simply cannot afford
it whichever region they happen to live
in it lies in empowering every part of
the country with the capacity and the
tools and the investment to deliver
sustained growth for themselves for too
long this relationship between national
and local government has been deeply
disrespectful based on dependence the
begging Bowl culture that the mayor of
the West Midlands rightly excoriated
last week we seek a new relationship of
equals based on mutual respect a
covenant between National regional and
local partners and most of all the
people that we serve so by the end of
our first term we want to see a
significant expansion of economic
Devolution in England with local leaders
using a range of powers to drive growth
and prosperity in communities across the
country
now I'm going to be honest that will
last more of many of you in this room
than has ever been asked before because
the Frontline Workforce Who deliver the
services that sustain jobs in growth and
the investors who stand ready to play
their part in rebuilding Britain's
Public Services the social housing the
town centers the physical infrastructure
they can only build a country that works
if they have national and local leaders
who have a vision and the ambition skill
and staying power to see it through
who are prepared to embrace a different
sort of leadership from the broken
models that have cost us the trust of
the British people felt most acutely at
National level but without any question
in many local communities to one that is
far more open accountable transparent
willing to partner with whoever it takes
business and Workforce across political
boundaries and govern not to the people
but with the people that we serve now I
know that's a lot to ask 13 stormy years
have battered our communities and local
government has been asked to step up
over and over again leading this country
through the pandemic when central
government floundered the last line of
defense for children broken by hunger
and homes without heat in the winter our
councils have been hollowed out burnt
out trying to spin gold out of thread
for a decade takes its toll and it's
tempting to look back on previous
decades when the Taps were on and
funding flowed from National to local
and to seek only this a better resource
dependent relationship in which a small
group of people would continue to hold
all the power
I say to replicate such a system would
squander the Visionary leadership that
we've heard today in this room
we can do so much better than this we
have to do better than this our broken
political system is no longer negotiable
it must change or die and it is
precisely in these times when so much is
broken where nothing is certain where so
much is at stake that real change
becomes not just possible but inevitable
and this is what's at stake we're
standing here today in the city that I
was born in 40 years ago we're just a
few miles from here in the mines and the
Mills and the factories we built this
country's wealth and influence and we
gave the world the free trade Hall the
first Free Library we're a city shaped
by waves of immigration that have
changed and developed and empowered this
country over centuries
and that's how I know drawing on the
history that we have and the ambition
that we have that we here in the north
can build the country that we've
believed in all of our lives but not yet
seen a confident country big diverse and
generous enough
contain all its people and celebrate the
contribution that we have to make in
every part of Britain because across
every part of Britain in every part
Community despite all the Decay and the
drift of the last decade hope burns
brighter than ever before and there are
brilliant people ordinary people doing
extraordinary things so no more excuses
it's time to come together
it's time to build thank you
very much of the direction of travel
much more ambitious really and and
urgent than we heard from the Secretary
of State although the sort of agreement
really about devolving more power and
more finance and we're going to take a
couple of questions from the floor we're
also going to take one from Joseph
tyman from Manchester Evening
news so if you want to go to Mike's I'll
take a few questions I just
just want to ask
the take back controller would it work
on the basic structure that we have at
the moment of the the city regions the
combined mayoral authorities is that is
it is that the way it is going to be
based or are you going to reorganize
re-jig the unconfigure if you like the
jurisdictions
the current approach that we have that
imposes governance models on parts of
the country I believe it's deeply
undemocratic and there are many parts of
the country where people can see the
value in having combined authorities
yeah I live here in Greater Manchester
we've got a fantastic mayor in Andy
Berlin and it's done a lot for our
region that we've got someone and with
that stronger voice and that commitment
to place and that rooted in Partnership
working across greater Manchester to
deliver for us but it works because
there's some economic geography similar
scale can say I'll do it as well yeah
but this is there's a key reason why we
believe that you have
skills and the resources that go behind
sales investment into local and Regional
hands it's because you cannot drive
local growth without being able to skill
up young people to get those jobs you go
to somewhere like Barrow and you talk to
young people who can see these
incredible world-leaving jobs from their
Primary School Playgrounds but they'll
say to you I might as well try and go to
the Moon as to get those jobs well
that's going to change okay so skills
absolutely done deal
Andy made another another pitch this
morning which I think was an interesting
one which is really a kind of Barnard
formula for
big city regions or for at least part of
the country now it's an interesting one
because it's really as applied to
Scotland and Wales it's a it's a
population weighted kind of if you spend
it nationally you know if you spend it
on England they automatically get the
population equivalent
um just I'm just interested in whether
you think a kind of a single check model
it's like look you just spend it you can
have a whole lot we're spending this
much in your patch on everything police
and health and here's the money you sort
it is
because in a way that is The Logical
extension that's what we do with
Westminster does in Scotland is don't
take it that far and why wouldn't you
take it that
so I think there is a growing political
political census now that single budget
settlements with far more Flex in the
budget not just for Mayors and combined
authorities but for local authorities
and groups of local authorities working
together it's the future but I think we
need to be more ambitious than just
thinking about expanding this model
where national government hands over
resources and local and Regional
government is able to spend it in one of
the great problems that we've had in
this country is that because Mayors and
councils have to go begging as and the
street said cap in hand to Westminster
and Whitehall they become accountable
upwards but not downwards to the people
that they serve now there's a reason why
you know
taking control of our bosses in Greater
Manchester took some time and it's not
just because Andy has had to fight an
ongoing battle with the bus providers in
order to take back Democratic control
it's also because we've had to raise
some of that money locally and it's
meant that he's been out in every part
of Greater Manchester making the case to
people for why that should be done and
gaining their consent so that model of
raising money locally and accounting
locally for how you spend it that is
where I think we ought to be aiming for
you can't do it overnight it would
collapse local economies that are
already falling further and further
behind but ultimately we should be
ambitious enough to think that the goal
for this incredible region the north of
England that has powered this country in
living memory and can do it again is to
be able to raise our own money stand on
our own two feet and accounts the people
we serve for how we do that okay let's
take um is Joseph from the Manchester
United Jones if your question we're
getting one from the Press here yeah go
ahead
thanks hi Lisa
um so we heard this morning
um about learning lessons about leveling
up from East Germany
um growth in East Germany was driven by
cities not towns and villages
as far as I understand
um would growth be driven by cities
under labor what role would tons of
villagers play under a labor government
you know one of the great challenges
that we've got in here in Britain is
that we've got these great inequalities
between regions but we've also now got
inequalities within regions that are
even bigger and if we really want to be
serious about the north of England as
the PowerHouse of Britain then we've got
to take seriously closing that Gap it
was Tracy you said to me a while ago you
know investors come they want to invest
in Leeds it's the Golden Goose but you
know Bradford has so much potential so
much to offer to why she went off a fort
for Bradford to become the city of
culture as part of this vision of a
northern Corridor of arts and culture
that kick-starts regeneration and grows
local economies and gets money back into
people's pockets and fulfills the
potential of most people across the
region I believe that we need a model
like that across the whole of Britain
because if you look at those industries
of the future we've got amazing
universities in our major cities that
are powering us ahead on things like
life sciences and partnering with with
companies outside of the major cities in
places like Burnley who are still
powerhouses in manufacturing but look at
the potential for clean energy it's in
our Coastal and Industrial towns that
within living memory powered the world
and could do again that's why we say you
don't just need one National growth plan
or even just one model of city-led
growth you need to be thinking about the
potential and the assets that exist in
all places across all parts of the north
but it is interesting isn't it because
the London model in the south of England
is much more a commuter model of people
from scattered towns around going in
there and working and then go back home
in the evening
um do you find do you think that model
has anything to teach the north they're
essentially towns I mean your
constituency we're going to becomes more
of a place for people to live and
commute into Central Manchester for work
as a kind of an economic Hub where you
get those so-called agglomeration
benefits as economists would describe it
that model hasn't delivered for anybody
over the last few decades it
a million people make their home in
London every year trying to find better
work
since his I know because 20 years ago I
was one of them and I did find those
things but what I also found were the
cripplingly high housing costs that are
blighting an entire generation I found
struggling Public Services I found these
huge extremes of inequality of poverty
and wealth existing side by side it's
just not sustainable for any part of the
country if you undercook some parts of
our economy you overheat others so that
now disposable incomes in London when
you account for housing costs are lower
than nearly every region in the country
even the winners are losing and I think
we can do far far better
right I want to let's take one from the
we've got to take one from the floor
we'll take you're waving your hand so
enthusiastically can we run the mic down
the ear keep your hand up so the uh mic
person knows one from the floor and then
we better go to T yeah okay go okay tell
us who you are we like to know hello
Lisa uh Elizabeth Cameron um also chair
of the GM racing quality panel and I'd
like to be able to speak to you about
working people so everything that
everybody's talked about today is really
wonderful but I guess where I meet it's
at is as a trade unionist I I hear from
Working Class People they simply cannot
live at this moment you know we've we've
all seen what's happening with the
strikes so I I'd like to hear what you
would say about that because then I
align that with the lives of ethnically
diverse people who of course then come
underneath that level even further
um you know we're black and Asian women
four times more likely to die in
childbirth you know some some figures
that frankly you know we just don't want
to live with young black men more likely
to go to jail than to University and so
there's a massive bridge to you know a
gap if you like that needs a bridge
before we come to this place where we
say let's give it to the community they
can do it they're lacking confidence
they're lacking skill and they've failed
we saw it happen before with my side so
I'll stop talking but yeah you get that
question it's a really good question
thank you very much yeah so I mean this
is one thing that
13 years as a member of Parliament and
five years as a local councilor before
that it's that if you had power to
people who have staken the outcome and
skinned in the game they work harder
they try more they do for longer they're
more creative than anybody else because
they can do no other I learned that
force and first and foremost from mums
and it was largely mums who've been
through my constituency surgery over the
last decade who have children with
special educational needs they have
taken on opaque systems over and over
again and they always win regardless of
background educational qualifications
levels of confidence because it matters
so much and I genuinely believe that if
you hand power over things like skills
and procurement and trade to our local
and Regional leaders people who without
exception I'm looking at this front row
of our fantastic leaders all of them
live in raise their family in and belong
to the communities that they they serve
they know that if you raise the wages of
people who are really struggling if you
protect the wages and working conditions
of people whether it's our National
Health Service or the BT open reach
workers whoever it is you're getting
money back into people's pockets they're
going out and spending it on local high
streets you're regenerating your local
economies and you're staving off all of
those massive problems that we've seen
from this broken National model of
soaring up mental health crises and
fractured families and communities that
are struggling to get by that's why
moving power matters in the end it's not
because we care more about who holds
power about the structures the
institutions the processes because of
the outcomes it's because of what that
delivers for people
thank you for that we should just end
this session on saying that the logic of
devolution and you're really going for
it with the Take Back Control Act
is that you do let local governments
fail sometimes right because it is
unlikely they're all going to be
spectacularly good all of the time so
you have to have the situation where you
say you've screwed up it is not the
Whitehall Minister's job to to to take
responsibility or accountability voters
in that area you just sort of boot out
those idiots and get someone else in
because they will fail sometimes won't
they yeah of course they will but I just
challenge you evidence of walking to any
ale Department try and get them a train
try getting a bus I don't know if you're
traveling
across the north of England and I can
tell you that failure is not confined to
local government no no it's 10 years
[Applause]
of devolution is that other people may
fail sometimes as opposed to central
government
one very quick thing about that before
you kick me off stage it's that I I'm
you know of course there'll be they'll
be failure I can't imagine for a moment
there would be failure on the scale that
we're dealing with in Britain right now
but what I would say to you too is that
the bigger challenge I think having
spoken to successive uh secretaries of
State who've tried to do this in various
ways under the last Labor government of
the previous conservative government and
under the Cameron Administration is that
the bigger challenge actually is that
we've got to get comfortable with
different parts of the country doing
things differently that that is The
Logical consequence yeah people if
everyone feels oh it's postcode lottery
I don't get the same bus cap in in this
area to bus fare Academy is there is a
better area well we've got one now we
have in fact
if you move if you move power outward to
different places do things differently
you don't like it you can get rid of
your local leaders how do you do it
right now largely you can't we can do
better than that right we need to go to
tea but I think we should thank Lisa
[Applause]